[Music]
holy crap everybody they're totally
going there in Titan season one so we
have new information on a character that
they're casting for episodes 11 and 12
of Titan season 1 and it basically reads
like Trigon in his human form so I'll
explained the mechanics of that because
there's this whole season 1 season 2
thing like how are they gonna go
straight to Trigon if he's this grand
cosmic villain to run a break from
filming episodes for the holiday but
they go back and the next week or so so
I'll explain what the schedule is and
where they're at and they're filming in
which characters they've already
confirmed like the really big ones if
you are just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos but starting with Trigon first so
over the reason why I put that clip at
the beginning is because it sort of
explains this character description that
they're casting for the human form of
Trigon the fake name that they have on
this casting notice is Evan Logue male
late 30s to 40s Caucasian charismatic a
cult leader attempting to reunite his
family wink wink
from behind the camera central role for
series finale recurring guest star
please submit star cameo names casting
for early wardrobe but the role works
from episodes 11 to episode 12 and then
it even has the filming dates that gives
you an idea for when they're going to be
filming the finale because they're
supposed to be 13 episodes and if this
handsome looking guy is done with
episode 12 what might happen is is they
reveal trigons true form in the actual
finale so from a production standpoint
it's sort of like the way the Darth
Vader works like you have different
actors playing the physical part and
then you have a different actor doing
the voice part and if you're not a big
comic book reader Raven herself the
animated version of the character does a
really good job of explaining her
backstory and who Trigon is what the
church' Bloods involvement in all this
is during this clip so here we go so mom
with her great powers of judgment didn't
hesitate to hook up with a guy who
emerged from the smoke
[Music]
whoa wait so your mom did it with Seaton
his name is Trigon but basically yes
but they totally did it Garfield that
was inappropriate go on it gets weirder
mom thud the cult I was on the run with
nowhere to go when she gets saved by
these people from another dimension
the people of Asura a realm of beauty
peace and tranquility where needless to
say I did not fit in but I must have
been heretonight arrabal judgment
because I thought if I found out more
about the monster who made me I'd be
able to make sense of myself
so as you can see pretty simple
explanation Trigon mates with a human
woman creates a half human half demon
child through which he can enter the
world so that's how he gets into our
dimension and then just destroys
everything then does it in another
dimension so on so forth until he
controls all of reality the really good
analogy for this is kind of what they
did in guardians of the galaxy - with
ego the Living Planet although they
changed ego the Living Planet SPAC story
so Marvel DC completely different
stories but make all the jokes you want
about people creating half human half
God children because we haven't seen an
actual costume for Raven we don't know
if she has the jewel that traps Trigon
in her forehead she very literally
becomes the only prison that can hold
him in that jewel so she holds it in her
forehead so it's sort of this constant
psychic battle that he's waging with her
trying to get her to release him in
every once in a while when she's using
her powers too much or she loses her
[ __ ] she opens herself to that conduit
too much he takes over and sort of
supplants her mind which is when she
starts to look like this so it'll be
interesting to see if during the course
of the series she loses her [ __ ] and she
actually gets the full Trigon face they
would probably do that part practical
effects part CG but it'll be cool to see
it in a live-action for the first time
but I feel like this is our confirmation
that Trigon will officially be the big
bad of season one before we learned
about them casting Trigon I actually
thought the brother blood would be the
big bad and he's the head of the Church
of blood the Church of blood is the cult
that Raven is talking about in that clip
that I played when she says her mother
joined a cult
so you can see what they're building
tours so of course there's a bunch of
different big bill and organizations
that the Teen Titans fight in the comics
and they're doing anything from the Teen
Titans comics even though the series is
called Titans remember the story arc
that they did during the flash season
one have they told the story of Barry
learning about how his mother died and
then it led into the flashpoint
storyline eventually this is sort of
Titans starting off with a story like
that one of the most seminal epic
stories ever and if you want to go read
it it's called the terror of Trigon but
it's from the New Teen Titans comic book
title there are a bunch of different
Teen Titans comics but it's basically
the story of how he come
to earth which is what they did for
Justice League vs Teen Titans the
animated movie you can also watch that
too but obviously that doesn't include
everything from the comics and they
changed some of the characters and
obviously after Trigon the biggest
character it sounds like they're doing
is their version of Bruce Wayne when
they're doing flashbacks to when Robin
was younger like they open episode 1 and
they're filming a Gotham fight scene so
it sounds like he's still Robin and he
hasn't decided to break out on his own
but it could be a flashback that they're
filming it's just that Brenton Thwaites
was like filming a scene and got them in
his Robin costume so you do the math on
that but the actor that it sounds like
they're casting for Bruce Wayne is
recurring but it's like the way the
flash TV show treats flashbacks you only
do them every once in a while when
they're really important when the
character is thinking about something
that happened in the past I know
everybody wants to hear that Wally's
going to Titans they haven't confirmed
where he's going next I think that
Legends is probably a stronger
possibility in the short term but long
term anything is possible so let me know
in the comments what do you think about
them doing Trigon on Titans you just
leave all your bonus video requests in
the comments below we're still gonna
have a couple more weeks before the
shows come back but there'll be some
more trailers in the next week or two
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is just be a subscriber or leave a
Titans related comment on the video and
congratulations to the winner from my
last video LJ Rogers please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so it can get your contact details click
here to learn about the Young Justice
season 3 release date and click here for
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight